last time on World War Z Brad Pitt and
director Marc Forster went through a
well-documented feud weaning to
extensive reshoots and an out-of-control
budget can Brad Pitt save this film from
bad word of mouth and a ton of
production problems by now
today odd world more si
World War Z is directed by Marc Forster
and stars Brad Pitt or the Liam Neeson
of the UN as this movie portrays him to
be he's the guy with all the skills you
never really know exactly what it is
that he does he's just really good in
the field he's clever and he's smart and
he's not afraid of zombies so they sent
him out into the zombie apocalypse to
try to figure out exactly how it started
and how they can stop it now it's been
very well documented that this movie
went through a ton of problems during
its production they had to reshoot large
portions of this movie because they saw
the way it was going and they decided
that they didn't like the way that film
was going the direction it was taking
was this heavy political message and
they felt it was too convoluted and they
decided to make a fun summer action film
which in my opinion probably saved this
movie because World War Z actually is a
fun film to watch I had an enjoyable
time with World War Z despite my
incredible shock because I really didn't
think this movie looked that great that
being said the movie does have issues
though and a lot of them are around the
story structure and you can really kind
of feel that this movie did have a lot
of overhauls and a lot of things were
cut out and changed and altered a lot of
the movie does feel a little bit strange
and cut up like certain things have been
placed that weren't there and now they
kind of shifted a few things around but
remarkably the movie actually holds up
fairly well and Brad Pitt is one of my
favorite actors and I think he did a
really good job in this movie portraying
the character as this stoic badass type
but at the same time he was protective
of his family when it needed to be and
even though that is a very common
character I think that he did a good job
with it and you could kind of look
beyond the Brad Pitt thing because when
a star gets to a point where he's so
famous it's difficult for him to portray
a character like Tom Cruise I know faces
that similar issue where he it's hard
not to see Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt
sometimes it's hard not to see Brad Pitt
but I think Brad Pitt does a pretty good
job in this movie and he really has to
hold up the whole movie because he is
the star of the movie and he really is
the star of this movie I mean there were
supporting characters that drift in and
out of the scenes but Brad Pitt has his
whole movie on his shoulders it really
seems like it should have been rated our
movie because you can tell that a lot of
the more grotesque or intense moments
were blocked away by certain things or
hidden from camera and I don't really
have a problem with that I just feel
like this movie would have benefited
from an r-rating I think that they
improved the CGI quite a bit from that
first initial trailer it'll just look
like cartoon really and in that way I
was very pleased because that first
trailer it really just looked like
cartoon
zombies were coming after Brad Pitt and
I'm glad they were able to fix that I
can't really get into one of my main
issues with the film because it is a
major spoiler so I'll get my way around
it without spoiling it certain ways the
film concluded just felt too simple and
like really okay that's all I can really
say without spoiling it for you which I
don't want to do World War Z does have
story and structure issues there's
barely any character development you
really just get that one opening scene
where Brad Pitt and his family are
eating breakfast I thought World War Z
was an enjoyably fun movie there isn't
much else to it really except the big
zombie action set-pieces that are
entertaining to watch but doesn't have
much else to offer besides that I think
my favorite scene in the movie was the
set piece that was not shown in any of
the trailers at this health facility
which I thought was really well done and
a lot of fun really intense a lot of
suspense sneaking around you know
holding an axe through a hallway very
cliched zombie stuff but I eat that
stuff up when it's done well I love that
eat that stuff up that's a zombie pun
that I did not mean to make so overall
despite some story flaws an obvious
reshooting and restructuring of the film
that you can kind of tell is there and
as a parent I enjoyed World War Z and
I'm gonna give it a B so thanks as
always for watching guys I'm interested
in knowing what you guys thought of the
movie - if you'd like to comment below
thanks again and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck
minimized
[Music]